- All right, before we go,
(audience cheering)
I wanna share something super cute
I found scrolling social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
So we talk a lot on this show
about how we can make kids
more interested in reading.
That's why I love what one
Milwaukee teacher is doing
to engage his first grade students.
He turns reading and writing
into catchy, interactive songs
like his beloved "Punctuation Chant!"
- Question mark.
- [Students] Question mark.
- Asks a question.
- [Students] Asks a question.
- How are you?
- [Students] How are you?
- Voice lifts up.
- [Students] Voice lifts up.
- How you doing, friend?
- [Students] How you doing, friend?
- Exclamation point!
- [Students] Exclamation point!
- Strong and loud.
- [Students] Strong and loud.
- Hey, you!
- [Students] Hey, you!
(audience cheering)
- I love him, adorable.
We have that educator
on the line right now,
watching on TMJ4.
Let's say hi to Jake, y'all.
What's up Jake?
(audience cheering)
- Hi, how are you?
- I am so good.
But first and foremost,
thank you so much for being an educator.
We appreciate you so much,
(audience cheering)
value you.
So how did you start with this technique?
It's very memorable.
- Oh my goodness.
Well, thank you.
Honestly, so I am a little
bit of an extra person,
as you can tell,
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
but, honestly, I saw a need for it.
You know, we see some
huge proficiency problems
in America in reading,
and the research shows us
we have to teach the explicit code,
the sounds and the symbols.
And a lot of people say,
"Well, that's boring,"
or "That takes the joy away."
And so I thought, "Well, why
don't we add some motion,
some songs, and some chants
so that it's not boring."
And then now here I am.
(audience laughing)
- I love you so much,
oh my gosh.
What do the students' parents think?
Do they get involved?
Because if I walked into
my kids' classroom you do,
I would join, so.
(audience chuckling)
'Cause I'm also extra, I
don't know if you noticed.
- I actually do invite the
parents every month to join in.
So they actually do join
us for phonics every month.
And they get to do the
lesson along with us.
But honestly, Kelly,
the the sweetest response I've gotten
is from parents all over the globe.
And it's been like the authenticity piece.
So I don't look like a lot of teachers
that you would expect in your brain
when you think of an
elementary teacher, right?
I act and sound a little different.
And I have so many messages from parents,
like, "Thank you for letting our kids see
what authenticity is."
- Oh.
- And so
it's been like unreal.
I would've never expected
such a outpouring
of love from parents that have kids
that maybe feel like they
didn't used to fit in,
and they can be themselves.
- That is beautiful.
What a beautiful purpose
other than the major one
you're already doing.
Like that's incredible.
I'm glad that they voiced that as well,
'cause it's very important for everybody
to feel like, you know, they
fit in somewhere, right,
And you find your people.
So I'm liking your post
right now, right?
(bell dings)
- Yay. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- And that's not all, that's not all.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor your truly
unstoppable just manner
and way you teach.
It's a very beautiful thing.
So what they're gonna do
is they're just gonna write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much, Jake.
We love you.
- And thank you to all
our guests this hour,
Kelsey Grammer, Charles
Melton, M.J. Acosta.
Y'all have a great day.
(audience cheering)
If it's not, try and change it.